because there are interesting quirks
you know you know nietzsche with his if
you gaze long into the abyss the abyss
gazes into you
um how's this theories these ideas
change you as a person
it's been very very difficult
this stuff is not just abstract
theory building because it's about us
sometimes i realize that there's this
big division of me my mind is doing all
this science and and coming up with
these conclusions and the rest of me is
not integrating i was just like i don't
believe it i just don't believe this i
mean it seems so as i start to take it
seriously it's get i get scared myself
it's like
but it's very much then i read these
spiritual traditions and realize they're
saying very very similar things it's
like
there's a lot of conversion so for me
i
have
the first time i thought
it might be possible that we're not
seeing the truth
was in 1986
it was from some mathematics we were
doing
and
when that hit me it hit me like a ton of
bricks i had to sit down it was
it it really
it was scary it was really a shock to
the system
and then to realize that everything that
has been important to me like
you know
getting a house
getting a car
getting a reputation and so forth
well that car is just like the car i see
in the virtual reality it's there when
you perceive it and it's not there
so
the whole question of you know
what am i doing and why what what's
what's worthwhile doing in life
clearly
getting a big house and getting a big
car
i mean we all knew that we were going to
die
so we we
we tend not to know that we tend to hide
it especially when we were young before
age 30 we don't believe we're going to
die but yeah we factually maybe know
that you you kind of are supposed to
yeah but but they'll figure something
out and yeah believe the generation that
is the first one that doesn't have to
die that's the kind of thing but but
when you really face the fact that
you're going to die
and then when you when i start to look
at it from this point of view that well
this thing was an interface to begin
with
so what i'm really is what i'm really
going to be doing
just taking off a headset so i've been
playing in a virtual reality game all
day and i i got lost in the game when i
was fighting over a porsche and i i shot
some guys up and i punctured their tires
and by got the porsche now take the
headset off and what was that for
nothing there was just it was a data
structure and the data structure is gone
so so all of the wars the fighting and
the reputations and all the stuff you
know
where it's just a headset
so now and you know so my theory says
that intellectually
my my
mind my my emotions
rebel all over the place this is like i
you know
and so so i have to imagine i meditate a
lot well what percent of the day would
you say you spend as a physicalist
um
sort of living life pretending your car
matters
your reputation matter like
like how much uh was that tom wait song
i like my town with a little drop of
poison how much poison do you allow
yourself to have i think my default mode
is physicalist right i think that that's
just the default i i
when i'm not
being conscious
yeah consciously attentive
intellectually consciously
because if you're just you're still if
you're tasting coffee and not thinking
or drinking or just taking in the sunset
you're not being intellectual you're but
you're still experiencing it right so
it's when you turn on the like the
introspective machine that's when you
can start and turn off the thinker when
i actually just start looking without
thinking
so that's that's when i feel like i
all of a sudden i'm starting to see
through
sort of like okay
part of part of the addiction to the
interface is all the stories i'm telling
about it's really important for me to
get that really important to to do that
all so i'm telling all these stories and
so i'm all wrapped up
almost all the mind stuff that's going
on in my head is about
attachment to the interface
and so
what i found
is that
the
essentially the only way to really
detach from the interface
is to
[Music]
literally let go of thoughts altogether
and then all of a sudden
even my identity of you know my whole
history my name my education and all
this stuff
is almost irrelevant because it's just
now
here is
the present moment
and this is this is the reality right
now and all of that other stuff is an
interface story
but this conscious experience right now
this is the only
this is the only reality as far as i can
tell
the rest of it's a story
and
but that is again
not my default
that is i have to make a really
conscious choice to say okay i know
intellectually this is all an interface
i i'm going to take the headset off and
so forth
and
and
and then immediately sink back into the
game and just
be out there playing the game and get
lost in so i'm always lost in the game
unless i
literally consciously choose
to stop thinking
isn't it terrifying
to acknowledge that
to look beyond the game
isn't it uh
scares the hell out of me
it really is scary
because i'm so attached i'm attached to
this body i'm attached to the interface
are you ever worried about breaking your
brain
a bit
meaning like
it's uh
i mean some of these ideas when you
think about reality even with like
einstein
just realizing you said interface just
realizing that
light
you know that there's a speed of light
and you can't go fast in the speed of
light and like what kind of things black
holes and
can do with light even that can mess
with your head
yes
but that's still space time
that's a big mess but it's still just
space time it's still a property over
interface that's right but you it's
still like even so
even einstein realized that this
particular thing some of the stories we
tell ourselves is constructing
interfaces
that are
oversimplifying the way things work
um because the it's nice the stories are
nice
stories are nice this repeat i mean just
like video games they're nice
right and but einstein was a realist
right he was a famous realist in this in
the sense that he he
was very explicit in 1935 paper with um
podesta and rosen the epr paper where he
he
they said
if without
in any way
disturbing a system
i can predict with probability one
the outcome of a measurement
then
there exists in reality
that element
right that that value that
and we now know from quantum theory that
that that's false
that einstein's idea of local realism is
is strictly speaking false
yeah and and so
we can predict we can set up in quantum
theory you can set up and there's
there's a paper by chris fuchs quantum
bayesianism
where he
he scouts this out it was done by the
people but he gives a good presentation
of this where they have a sequence of
like something like nine different
quantum measurements that that you can
make
and you can predict with probability one
what a particular outcome will be but
you can actually prove
that it's
impossible that the
value existed before you made the
measurement so you know with probability
one what you're going to get but you
also know with certainty that that value
was not there until you made the
measurement so so we know from quantum
theory that the act of observation is an
act of fact creation
and that is
built into what i'm saying with this
theory of consciousness if consciousness
is fundamental
space time itself is an act of fact
creation it's it's an interface that we
create consciousness creates plus all
the objects in it so local realism
is not
true quantum theory is established that
also non-contextual realism is not true
and that that
fits in perfectly with this idea that
consciousness is fundamental
these things are these exist as data
structures when we create them
as as chris fuchs says the act of
observation is an act of fact creation
but i must say on a personal level
i'm having
to spend
i spend a couple hours a day
just sitting in meditation on this
and
facing
the rebellion
in me that goes to the co it feels like
it goes to the core of my being
rebelling against these ideas so so here
is very very interesting for me to look
at this because so here i'm i'm a
scientist and i'm a person
the science is really clear
local realism is false non-contextual
realism is false space time is doomed
it's very very clear it couldn't be
clearer
and my my emotions rebel left and right
when i sit there and say okay
i am not something in space and time
something inside of me says
you're crazy of course you are and i'm
completely attached to it i'm completely
attached to all this stuff i'm attached
to my body i'm attached to the headset
i'm attached to my car
attached to people i'm attached to all
of it
and and yet i know as a absolute fact
i'm going to walk away from all of it
i'm going to die
you know
in fact i almost died last year i
coveted almost killed me it i i
i sent a goodbye text to my wife so i
was
i would i thought you really did i sent
her a goodbye i thought i was in the
emergency room
and uh it attacked my heart
and it been a 190 beats per minute for
36 hours
i i couldn't last much longer i knew i
would like they couldn't stop it
so so that was that was it so that was
it so so i texted her goodbye from the
emergency room
i love you goodbye kind of thing yeah
right yeah that was it so so were you
afraid
yeah this scares the hell out of you
right but there there is there was
you're just feeling so bad anyway that
that all you know you that sort of
you're scared but you're just feeling so
bad that in some sense you just want to
stop anyway yeah
so so i've i've been there
and faced it just just a year ago
how did that change you by the way
having having this intellectual reality
that's so challenging that you meditate
on that you're it's just an interface
and one of the
one of the hardest things to come to
terms with is that that means that you
know
it's going to end
how did i change you having come so
close to the reality of it it's not just
an intellectual reality it's
it's a reality of death
it's it's forced i've meditated for 20
years now
and then i would say averaging three or
four hours a day
um
but it's put a new
urgency
but
urgency is not the right word because
that that
it's it
it's riveted my attention i'll put it
that way
it's really riveted my attention and um
i've really paid
i spent a lot more time looking at what
spiritual traditions say
i don't by the way
again not taking it with the you know
take it all with a grain of salt
but on the other hand i think it's
stupid for me to ignore it so i try to
listen
to
the best ideas
and and to sort out
nonsense from
and it's just we all have to do it for
ourselves right it's not easy so what
makes sense
and i have the advantage of some science
so i can look at what science says and
try to compare with spiritual tradition
i try to sort it out for myself
and
but then i also look and realize that
there's another aspect to me which is
this whole emotional aspect
the
i i seem to be wired up
as
evolutionary psychology says i'm wired
up
right
all these defensive mechanisms you know
i'm inclined to lie if i need to i'm
inclined to
to be angry to protect myself to have an
in-group and an out group
to try to
make my reputation as big as possible to
try to demean the out group there's all
these things that evolutionary
psychology is spot on it's really
brilliant about the human condition
and yet i think evolution
as i said evolutionary theory
is a projection of a deeper theory where
there may be no competition
so how so i'm in this very interesting
position
where i feel like okay according to my
own theory i'm consciousness and maybe
this is what it means for consciousness
to wake up it's not easy
it's it's
it's almost like i have i feel like i
have real skin in the game
it really is scary i really was scared
when i was about to die
it really was hard to say goodbye to my
wife it really it really pained and
to then look at that and then look at
the fact that
i'm going to walk away from this anyway
and it's just an interface how do i so
it's it's trying to put all this stuff
together and really
grok it so to speak not just
intellectually but grocket
at an emotion what are you afraid of you
silly evolved organism that's gotten way
too attached to the interface
what are you really afraid of
that's right
is there a very personal you know it's
very very personal yeah
you